reading anyone with facial hair like
this definitely has herpes
this electric fence hole is even more
convenient than the one in Jurassic Park
342 if you read the book you know what
this means
I'm guessing Katniss knows exactly where
to turn her head to see Gale movie makes
Elizabeth Banks ugly well that was easy
futuristic flip buffs require three
fingers or is this British to woody
harrelson should never be anyone's
mentor
Haymitch is alcoholism is introduced and
then immediately solved the movie came
out in 2012 but the fire effects were
completed in 1995 she's not training
she's just playing memory how did this
girl get up here I used to decorate the
cakes down at the bakery right because
coal-mining just 412 where they eat
squirrels has a bakery with a fucking
cake decorator Hannah's shadow that's a
pretty racist thing to say this advice
should have been given a long time ago
I'm not about today and yet strangely
you are allowed to act how do Holograms
make these guys jobs any easier you
really need to vocally count down from
50 if you wanted to see the actual
Hunger Games themselves you'll need to
slog through an hour and eight minutes
of the film first director of
photography Michael J Fox builds awesome
trap she never uses this death montage
illustrates how unimportant these
characters are we interrupt this episode
of The Hunger Games to bring you the
Truman Show also if it's real forest
fire won't put itself out this lady's
job description is to describe things on
screen that are plainly seen and then
get a cannon rating if Haymitch can be
her sponsor and send her gifts then why
the did he waste all that time telling
her to do the things that get her
sponsors and gifts how did Will Smith's
daughter get up in the tree undetected
of course there's a wasps nest right
above the bad guys is she hallucinating
history mockingjays respond to any old
noise you happen to make this girl
conveniently shows Katniss exactly where
the landmines are and this guy goes
chasing after a noise he may be heard
how do they not see her you know this
might be a good time to use that healing
cream obligatory closing of the dead
eyes no cannons for these characters
that lady back at the home base must not
have done her job yeah this isn't a
waste of time or anything you do know
you could die at any minute right
shouldn't district 11 be used to their
tributes dying is a riot really
necessary isn't she just sitting out in
the open in plain view
so Katniss is sitting here crying in the
woods and then we cut the Haymitch
trying to persuade the double beard and
then we cut to the double beard trying
to persuade his grandpa and then we cut
back to Katniss still crying oh for
fuck's sake
I watched you going home every day every
day age differences at this point in
child development matter
Katniss should easily dominate this
other girl wanted to simply kill her a
minute ago now wants to monologue
Katniss has surprised the cream worked
even though she used it earlier if he
really is dead probably not wise to
shout his name at this point why yes
that is a dog the finale is a dog
correction the finale is several dogs
awesome bad guy appears out of nowhere
Katniss uses the arrow as a distraction
instead of a deadly weapon they were
okay with dogs possibly killing everyone
but the berries no way what happens
making it back I guess they try to
forget yeah me too
you
she should have released the dogs with
wasps in their mouths so when they bark
there she lost it